[Music]
during the u.s Civil War the Union Army
needed soldiers and so Congress enacted
a draft conducted by lottery
but the draft had an unusual provision
those who were conscripted had a choice
if you didn't want to fight in the Civil
War and if you had enough money you
could hire a substitute to take your
place
these days the u.s. like most countries
has an all-volunteer army of paid
soldiers no one is conscripted
some people argue it is more just to
recruit soldiers by paying them than by
conscripting them others argue that
using the market to decide who will
fight our Wars whether in the Civil War
way when the way of the all-volunteer
army
unfairly allows the affluent to buy
their way out of military service what
do you think is the most just way of
allocating military service conscription
by lottery with no buyout provision
conscription by lottery with a buyout
provision as in the Civil War or an
all-volunteer system where the market
decides who will fight our Wars
[Music]